i recall you talking about heraclitus
and saying that
it is both that the stream is the same
and that it's you then
that you don't step in the same river
twice it's more like
you're it's more like those are two
different modes of being with the river
or
the stream okay now see that's different
then
the standard analytical answer would be
the wittgenstein which is while you're
playing different
language games and so it depends on what
you mean by so-and-so but you're saying
you've changed it from the analytical to
saying no no it depends on how you be
okay yes mind outlining that briefly or
as lengthy as you like for the audience
i think that was incredibly insightful
in a way it's another way of saying
something i said before
which is that it's not
either or or both and
it's both either or and both and
so it is both true that the stream is
the same stream
and that it is a different stream
uh each of these has a sort of truth and
in a either orchestral mind you can go
well come on which
is it but in another way you can say
it's perfectly coherent that it is
both not actually because
in some part as i've just suggested with
an image of an island
but all the time uh it is
one and the other and
there are many things uh in in life
uh and in the wider
structure of things it seems to me that
have this dual
not dual quality exactly but this
unwillingness to
to finally split it into it's got to be
this way or that
in fact the further you go towards deep
things the more you find that
opposites um come together and i know
i'm hardly the first person to have said
that but it still needs to be said
is that still very much needs to be said
sorry
is that why you said at one point that
the logical mind while it reinforces
itself reinforcing
at its extreme you would get to the
right mind
well i think it to the extreme it ought
to be able to encounter its own bounds
so for example in a way girdle
demonstrated that a certain kind of
entirely logical thinking
eventually demonstrates its own
limitations
and pascal said that reason is feeble
indeed if it cannot see its own
limitations
and don't forget that pascal was a great
mathematician and logician
so um i mean as well as being
a great spiritual thinker
so if you take the left hemisphere thing
far enough it will encounter its own
self coming the other way and we
sometimes see this happening in the
world that if you take a
certain point of view far enough
if you take um an intolerant attitude
that's dogmatic and
cruel on the right and
a similar one on the left you can hardly
tell the difference it's in the
mentality it's in an approach to the
world
um and you know by going further and
further away to the
right or the left you don't avoid
the fate that you're trying to avoid the
nemesis will come to you if you insist
on having a black and white either or
way of thinking
so we must for our own sakes get back to
seeing that it's a both and world in
which
you may have truth on your side and i
may have truth on my side and we ought
to respect one another and talk about it
in a grown-up way not um
vilifying hating and silencing people
but
listening to people who say things
different from ourselves
that's so fundamental it's how our
civilization got to
have a culture and now we're throwing it
away
anyway sorry it does distress me very
much
this this sudden rise in in the not
being shades of meaning
i think it's to do with the way we're
educated i don't think we're taught any
longer to think
there's a phrase in greek in classical
greek
men there and then many
of the great philosophers of greek
they would say men on the one hand this
the on the other hand that and in a way
that was part of the way i was taught to
think that you should see
yes as good in that but there's there's
also something else to be said that's
you know you need to be aware of and
i i i i've in the last year or two come
across
a couple of zen sayings that i like very
much and i think i might write a book
with one or other title and one is
yes but and the other is not always
so and that really brings one back into
the world of the right hemisphere
because the right hemisphere
thinks yes but it's the one that always
says
uh yes but hang on it inhibits headlong
action it's actually more intelligent
and it literally is a more
intelligent hemisphere in the sense that
if you have damage to the left
hemisphere damage to the right
hemisphere
overall damage to the right hemisphere
will drop your iq
more than damage the light oh that's
extremely interesting i know that you
can function in the world more
adaptively if you have a left lesion
not the right lesion you can certainly
function more
because your emotional intelligence is
not impaired and your understanding of
human beings is not impaired
but your good old-fashioned cognitive
intelligence i
whatever it is iq measures is also more
highly dependent on
the right hemisphere than the left
anyway there's a study by barbie at al
in 2013 where they looked at um
150 people who'd had strokes and had a
pre-morbid iq
measurement and looked at their
post-morbid iq measurement
and the and then they put the maps over
the top of one another
and where were the really key areas for
dropping your intelligence hardly any
was in the left hemisphere interesting
almost all of them are in the right
hemisphere which is not of course
again part of that bad old caricature
difference between the left and right
houses well you know the right
hemisphere is all very well dear but
it's a bit you know kind of
not very reliable and silent but
yes but actually it's both more reliable
in the sense of more
likely to make the good decision and
more intelligent but anyway there we go
but let's say about inhibition because
you you
you said to me earlier on and then i
actually i really must stop
enjoying no no bless you
no i could i could talk to you all day i
wish we had time um
but i said early on something about
inhibition well here's a fascinating
thing
first of all the corpus callosum which
started up that's the
band of fibers that connects the two
hemispheres at the base of the brain
started out largely facilitatory in
other words it was largely
um conveying information from one to the
other hemispheres but it has now
come to the point where much of its
actual outcome
is inhibitory so much of what it is
doing is saying
you keep out of this you'll confuse the
picture i need to deal with this
and when the
mammalian brain evolved from you know
the mouse or whatever the shrew
up to ourselves if we can think of it as
a road upwards
um it involves more and more inhibitory
neurons
and mammals have more inhibitory neurons
primates have more inhibitory neurons
than other
non-primates and humans have more
inhibitory neurons than
any other primate and the
really important neurons
for uh the effectiveness of
carving experience coming back to the
idea that
that as it were like carving as a statue
in this
in the stone something only comes into
being by the
the turning away of something else so
the inhibition of the this is
discarding something that might have
been brings the thing into me
you could actually keep i mean i could
keep talking to your ages it's lovely